[Music]
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be what i want to
i put my law in it like no days off on a
road less travel never looking the
current setup right now with your
business what do you think is going to
be the biggest revenue driver is sub
stack do you think gonna drive you know
this paid newsletter business is that
going to drive a significant amount do
you think it's most going to come from
bt sport from youtube ads what how's
your your business set up and where's
your head at in terms of where the
opportunity is
right now uh my my biggest
revenue driver if if you want to put in
those terms is uh is vox media they're
they're paying me the most um and that
was important to me because the mma hour
was a show that i created and put a lot
of time and effort and uh you know just
i mean everything i poured everything
into that show
from 2009 all the way to 2018 and it was
heartbreaking to see it end even though
i was going to my dream job um that show
just meant so much to me and i think it
meant a lot to a lot of people and so
that's the biggest one and that's a do
you regard that as a youtube channel or
or
youtube and the and the the podcast does
very well it's on apple it's on spotify
it's on google it's on stitcher all
those places as well and you own it
i do not own it no i don't own it they
pay me to do that show uh so that's
what's interesting about my situation is
like some of the stuff i own some of the
stuff i don't own but everyone's playing
nicely together in this sandbox and i'm
very appreciative it took some time to
kind of
figure out all the pieces that was the
most interesting part of this like it
back in in february so when i came to
the conclusion that i was gonna go and
leave espn and try to do things here and
there
obviously you have oh i'd like to do
this and that like some people call it a
chinese menu you know you kind of build
your out your own thing but then
the actual
dance of getting everyone to play nice
and be on board with all these little
different things that i'm doing was the
most interesting part of the whole
process and i really lucked out and i
found all these people like people who
are okay with me having my own youtube
channel that's completely mine and the
sub stack but also doing something for
the ringer spotify and also doing
something for vox and b so um it's just
it's just been a really interesting um
exercise in look i i like my friend uh
pat mcafee here i am dropping uh names
um he's like oh well you're not totally
independent you don't own everything i'm
like okay fine if you want to get you
know uh into that whole semantics game
fine i don't own everything but there's
an independent spirit to all of this
where at the end of the day i feel like
i'm partnering with other people as
opposed to being a full-time employee
with anyone i'm not i have an llc now
and i'm able to pick and choose what i
want to do um and so that's that's
really important but to answer your
question
the biggest deal that i have at the
moment is
my deal with vox media
you do you think long term that stays
true or do you think cause some things
are are some things pay off better
immediately and then some things you say
okay
if i build i don't know the newsletter
if i build the the podcast or the ring
or stuff if i build that up three years
from now this picture might look a
little different or do you you said you
don't really think too much about
business do you not even care about that
you just do your thing and see what
happens are you trying to get me to
reveal my five year plan my business
plan right here are you that's exactly
what i'm trying to do i'm looking for 20
30 ariel where's 20 30 ariel doing like
the the what who's the guy who started
the ringer what's his name again bill
simmons yeah like you know he was in a
similar position as you so the ringer
probably netted 150 200 million dollars
when he did that i mean is that gonna
happen to to you
uh that would be nice um i don't know
you know
right now
um
obviously i'm i'm very happy with the
situation i'm really excited and it's
kind of the thing that's flying under
the radar at the moment which i'm
totally okay with that
uh what i'm doing on my own youtube
channel is giving me uh as i like to say
a lot of nachas nachas is a yiddish word
which means kind of like fulfillment and
joy in my heart because uh every week
for now every thursday i am posting an
interview with someone outside of the
mma world because i have been itching
for a very long time and that was part
of the reason why i went to espn
um to show people that i'm more than
just an mma guy that i can interview
other athletes authors musicians
comedians anyone it doesn't matter if
you're in the sports world if you're an
actor if you're a holocaust survivor if
you're interesting i want to talk to you
because the thing that i derive the most
enjoyment from
are the interviews i love talking to
people i could do a hunt i mean i do a
four-hour show twice a week now and uh i
i feel like i could do it every day it's
just a lot of uh fun for me and so i've
i started that around a month and a half
or so ago and uh it's just my own little
thing it's it's me and two producers an
audio guy video guy and we're posting
these interviews and i don't honestly
care at this moment if a million people
watch these interviews or
three people watch the interviews for
for me now i'm doing them to uh you know
fulfill you know this this little you
know
passion of mine to talk to other people
to scratch that itch but also to
eventually show people the right kind of
people
that i could do this that i could be
much more than just
an mma guy and it's actually the exact
same thought process that i had when i
got into all this back in 2007 in fact
uh this past tuesday october 19th
marked the 14-year
anniversary of me launching my own site
jerrypark.com it's still up
i was at spike tv
in september of 2007 i got a job working
at spike tv and spike tv was the home of
the ufc and i was working in tv
production i thought okay this is the
best place for me tv production ufc
uh they're the home of the ufc it's
perfect after a week there i walked into
my boss's office
and uh i quit and i said uh i i don't
really think this is the right fit for
me i'm not i really like they didn't do
anything creative i'm a creative guy i
like to think of ideas come up with
things and they were just kind of the
middlemen the ufc was producing all the
content so i walked into his office i
said i'm really sorry thank you for the
opportunity but i don't think this is
the right fit and i'm the kind of guy
who um when he's 85 years old i i don't
want to wake up and say i could have
done this i should have done this i
should have zigged when i zagged all
that stuff he was very upset he said
you're going to regret this for the rest
of your life this is unprofessional no
one's ever done this blah blah blah and
they made me stick around for a month
and a half in my cubicle until they
found someone to replace me and that was
the crossroads of my life
in fact our mutual friend john was a
part of this process where you know i
would we would go for lunch during this
process i'm not doing anything and i'm
telling him i'm going to start my own
website
and i'm going to start interviewing
fighters because i really want to go
into mma journalism i really want to
show people that i could be the howard
cosell the the max kellerman the
whatever of mma and so i started to
reach out to fighters via myspace and
every morning i would post an interview
with a fighter and i didn't care if five
people looked at the interviews or 500
000. i just wanted to use that to show
people that i could do that
14 years later i'm doing the same thing
on my youtube page and now i want to
build this and grow it um and and use it
as an opportunity to show people but for
now it's just like giving me so much joy
to go back to those early days and just
talk to people about things and then now
i'm like last week i interviewed marty
fish the former tennis player who's been
you know very open with his battles with
anxiety and friends of mine who have
never listened to my work watched my
work ever who don't care about mma are
like wow dude you're a really good
interviewer i'm like yeah i've been
doing this for 14 years at this point
but it's it's opening me up to a whole
new audience and i'm very excited about
that
[Music]